I rather love this it's it's Celia Celia
by Adrian Mitchell and I've chosen it
because it's very short and you can
learn poems easily but if you're just
starting out learning then perhaps learn
something which doesn't take a lot of
concentration I mean all our actors here
know how to learn huge amounts of lines
easily but once you've got something
inside of you it really belongs to you
and I understood this early on in life
because back to the old winterson
Madness she once burned all of my books
which was a terrible thing and then I
realized that anything that's outside of
you can always be destroyed taken away
at any moment and in a world where so
many people now refugees we know what
that might feel like and it might happen
to us so if you had nothing if you had
to leave if you had to take things away
what would you have inside you that you
could rely on and that you could depend
on and would you be able to recite
things to yourself and others in in that
stressful time and this is this is a
lovely wonderful poem about the glory of
Beauty and the joy of the body and sex
and just these simple animal Elemental
everyday Pleasures that make you feel
better about being a carbon-based human
in a silicon World
um Helene are you going to read it to us
go on so I guess I meant to know it by
heart I did it twice I read about her
Celia Celia Celia Celia
by Adrian Mitchell
when I am sad and weary
when I think all Hope Has Gone
when I walk along High hopen
I think of you with nothing on
[Music]
fabulous we'll go on to it again do it
again yeah do it again
how do we do it differently should I do
it quicker no any suggestions
when I think I'll hope as we could rap
to it when I'm sad and weary when I
think all hope is gone when I walk along
I hope and I I think of you with nothing
on
William just
yeah well I'll tell you what it shows it
shows a perm can be met read in many
ways so you're all going to learn that
okay when you go home tonight you got
two poems to learn tonight and that's
one of them oh yeah listen wait till you
see what's coming you're going to have
pages and pages of terms to learn okay
let's let's go on to our our next one
which again Jeanette is um one I think
you'll introduce for us yes and and
Sue's going to read this in a moment and
it's it's a perfect poem really to stop
beating yourself up in the crazy West
where we always think we have to be
doing something in order to improve
ourselves you know whatever it is the
latest self-help book um read it and
life will change well it won't and this
poem is actually only one will it um
I hope nobody in the audience has
actually written a self-help book and
about removing obstacles rather than
doing anything it's about being not
doing so go on do it be it I'm gonna be
it right now
um uh yes this is attributed to Rumi uh
the translator is unknown and it's
called your task
your task is not to seek for love
but merely to seek and find all the
barriers within yourself
that you have built against it
think about it
[Music]
brief yeah short ones obviously Jeanette
well I like long ones too that was very
enigmatic that yeah it is but it's the
sort of thing that you can carry with
you like a Talisman isn't it you know
some people carry around a rabbit's foot
you know or a lucky penny yeah he's
around a rabbit's foot
there's also a a more simple
uh analysis of it in a way which is lots
of people come and talk to me about
love and how often they find themselves
pursuing people who aren't interested in
them but how so often they turn away the
people who are
and I think it's something we all
recognize do we not that at times in
life actually the right partner the
right person for a relationship might be
standing right next to you and you're
busy looking at the one walking over the
hill
I got them going yeah do you think we
should have a shake hands with the
person next to you
William the next person
um a couple of months ago I was asked to
do a pharmacy and a talk to open a new
office building in London uh one of
those sort of co-working sites and I
spent the afternoon about three hours
listening to people's problems and
halfway through the security guard came
in and he said your 3 30 hasn't turned
up
can I take their place
and I said of course come and sit down
what's on your mind
and he said to me
I came out when I was 24 but I'm 32 and
I still haven't had a relationship
and I said that's very sad why do you
think that is he said I don't know I'm
I'm loving and I'm kind and I'm upbeat
and I'm positive
but I'm Muslim and I'm gay and I can't
be both
and I said you have to listen to this
poem this is written 700 years ago by
one of the greatest Muslim Poets of all
time
and it's all about how men can love each
other as well as women and I read it to
him and he burst into tears and I think
it was probably the most powerful
prescription or Pharmacy I've ever been
involved in and I think it's time for
you to all hear it
Tom
it happens all the time in Heaven by
hafez translated by Daniel ledinsky
it happens all the time in heaven
and someday
it will begin to happen again on Earth
that men and women who are married
and men and men who are
lovers
and women and women who give each other
light
often will get down on their knees
and while so tenderly
holding their Lover's hand
With Tears in their eyes
will sincerely speak saying
my dear
how can I be more loving to you
how can I be more
kind
[Applause]
William just listening to you tell that
story about that perm and the effect it
had on someone
you know it's almost a confessorial role
that you're in isn't it when you're
sitting there
maybe I I feel as though I'm
I'm a cipher or I'm holding hands
between that person and that poem I mean
it's it's an incredibly powerful and
wonderful feeling to be able to simply
just connect people
to the right poem for their needs and
that's all you really have to do and um
uh as I said I think we live in a world
where we want to talk to people but
we're a bit confused because social
media gives us the illusion that we're
talking to people all the time and we're
not really and um I think that makes us
even lonelier
um doing my pharmacy around the country
the most common ailment
is loneliness
and this is really exacerbated by this
strange Avatar world we live in where
people put up not themselves on social
media they don't sound miserable I'm
lonely or any of these things their
lives are filled with friends and likes
and so on and it makes everybody else
feel increasingly inadequate
Jeanette just ask William something
William do you think poetry in when you
do your poetry pharmacies around the
country do you think poetry can work for
people who think they're not interested
in poetry or poetry is not for them and
somebody might just say oh look there's
a tent I'll have a go definitely because
I think the p word gets in the way
um I'm sure we most of us feel the same
thing which is
um as we grow up a slight sense that
we've been failed by the intermediaries
in poetry the English teachers the
Librarians the booksellers somewhere
around 11 12 or whatever A lot of people
lose their confidence in being able to
read a poem or feeling that poetry is
for them but in the end
poetry is is just words trying to
um connect to you um in the same way
that prayer can be or liturgy can be and
so forth so yes I think it's accessible
to anyone but what's required in a way
is a little bit of hand-holding and most
important of all context
anything else which is sometimes almost
a re-reading of a poem it's the you know
we want poems to be read slowly because
we want them to sink in because it's the
layers of meaning and sometimes you
don't get them on a first oh definitely
you don't and that's why we say to
people read a poem Like a Prayer don't
read it like fiction or journalism read
it out aloud in your head or out aloud
if if you're able to if you're not on
the bus but but read it out aloud in
your head and read it five nights
running you know keep it by your bed
you'll get something completely
different from it every time and and as
the layers as it unlayers you'll pick up
and all the cadences and the lyricism
and the musicality
um and it will enrich you
do you think people have lost the
ability to concentrate to listen
well we're certainly we're certainly
affected by all of this and in that
sense one of the reasons why poetry
really helps in the modern world is on
the whole is quite concise
um so yes I do think our concentration
spans are dramatically affected I don't
know about you but I'm often sitting
reading a novel and after you know half
an hour or whatever I find my hand
reaching for that damn device and I'm
thinking why am I doing that I'm reading
a book nothing's changed nothing's
happened I think we have a serious
problem on our hands um which we're not
necessarily very good at engaging with
or being present
have you ever had somebody who's coming
to your Pharmacy and and patently not
listen to you reading them the poem
and not really taken on board always
angry indeed no because rather rather
than I was saying about oh you don't you
don't go to the doctor unless you're ill
on the whole unless you think there's
you need to everybody pretty much
everyone's coming to see me because they
want to talk about something and usually
the people who begin with
I'm fine
other people are first reaching for the
kleenex if I say I'd say half the people
I talk to reach for the kleenex in that
in a way it did speak to me sometimes
you go and you'll get when you go to the
pharmacy you might get given a medicine
you think that's rubbish didn't make any
difference yes um well if I put it wrong
yes but how much I wonder how much of it
is them talking to you that's what in a
way I'm had the same thought about it
that's true uh get unburdening yourself
is is half the battle but there is that
look of complicity on people's faces
when you've read a poem and you see that
they've taken it in and um that's the
real power
do you read it to them yes I do and then
I give them a printed copy to take away
and I had this lovely moment I got an
email from somebody from Liverpool
actually from I'd be not doing a
pharmacy with one of the mental health
units in Liverpool and um
she was
suffering from loneliness and I'd given
her four lines by her first
which are I wish I could show you when
you're lonely or in darkness
the astonishing light of your own being
four simple words are simple lines and I
gave her a printout and I said stick it
on your mirror learn it off by heart and
read it every morning to yourself and
she sent me an email and she said you
won't remember me but you know you saw
me in Liverpool those months ago and
last night I got home to my flat and it
had been burgled and in that awful way
that burglars do my everything was
everywhere and
um the only thing that hadn't moved she
said were those four lines of poetry
sticking on my mirror thank you she said
it got me through the night
oh
that's wonderful Jeanette yes the next
person oh it's Atlas isn't it I'm going
to get Sue to talk about this because I
know she loves it and I do too
um because I have an atlas complex I'm a
Virgo and so so is Sue so we probably
all think that we have to hold up the
entire world all the time but William
has a beautiful introduction to this
poem in in the book which I hope you'll
get answers because it really is it's a
splendid book
um where he talks about just the living
in the day-to-day of love and what love
needs in order to get through every day
and those acts of kindness which are
often really mundane and prosaic not
glamorous or operatic at all and this
poem is really about that and I was
thinking about it actually when I chose
and I was taking around some wood to my
ex-wife in the snow and thinking you
actually never lose the people that you
love even if you're not with them
anymore and you have to do things like
take them a bag of wood when it's
snowing
history because so much poetry is
written about the first flush of Love
isn't it yeah and about passion and sex
and actually what keeps a relationship
upright is the rather steady mundane
tasks of care
um so uh yesterday I washed and ironed
my girlfriend's onesie and popped it on
the pillow and that's I hope an act of
love
as well as housekeeping
um should I read it yeah I do really
love this but I genuinely love this poem
it's great so it's called Atlas as
Jeanette said and it's by UA fanthorpe
there is a Kind of Love called
maintenance
which stores the WD-40 and knows when to
use it
which checks the insurance and doesn't
forget the Milkman which remembers to
plant bulbs which answers letters which
knows the way the money goes
which deals with dentists and Road fund
attacks and meeting trains and postcards
to the lonely
which upholds the permanently rickety
elaborate structures of living
which is atlas
and maintenance is the sensible side of
love
which knows what time and weather we're
doing to my brickwork
insulates my faulty wiring laughs at my
dry rotten jokes remembers my need for
gloss and grouting
which keeps my suspect edifice upright
in air
as Atlas did the sky
[Music]
William what have we got next we've got
a poem called Voice by Anne Samson uh
which I discovered in the early 90s mid
90s
um and it's one of my favorites um we
all know about relationships as as see
rightly said you know that we there's so
many stages of love from infatuation to
help me to forget you please if you can
sort of imagine the whole range and I
love this one because this is really
about
not being too needy you may love each
other but if you if you're if your voice
is wrong
um you can begin to collapse a
relationship by missing out on how it
really all began
over to you Jason
voice voice
by Anne Sansom
call by all means for just once
don't use the broken heart again voice
I'm sick to death of life and women and
romance voice but with a little help
I'll try to struggle on boys
expect me the promise and the cursed
voice the answer phony call me please
when you get in voice
the Nobody Knows the Trouble I've seen
boys
the I'd value your advice voice
I want the how it was voice
They Call Me Irresponsible but aren't I
nice voice they're such a bastard but I
want them in advance voice
that we all have weaknesses and mine is
being Wicked voice
the life's short and wasting time is the
only Vice voice the stay in touch but
Out Of Reach voice
I want to hear the things it's better
not to Broach voice
the things it's wiser not to voice voice